Sridhar Komalla: Yeah. Hi, I am Sridhar Kamala. Today we are going to talk about what is Java.
Sridhar Komalla: Java is a high level class based object. Oriented programming language that follows the principle of right once run anywhere.
Sridhar Komalla: Here are its keywords, key features are object, oriented, platform, independent, secure, and robust, multi-cred, distributed computing support.
Sridhar Komalla: Rich standard library main uses are android apple development, enterprise, software web applications, server side development games, IoT applications
Sridhar Komalla: and mainly technical characters are strongly typed language.
Sridhar Komalla: automatic memory management and garbage collection.
Sridhar Komalla: extensive error handling rich ecosystems of frameworks and libraries, architecture components.
Sridhar Komalla: Jdk, Java runtime environment. Java virtual machine.
Sridhar Komalla: So yeah, this is a simple Java. Hello, world example. This code is compiled with Java Byte code.
Sridhar Komalla: Run on. Jvm. Executed on any platform with Jre. Installed.
Sridhar Komalla: Okay, so if you would like to more details about Java history.
Sridhar Komalla: it is created by James Bosling at some Microsystems in 1995,
Sridhar Komalla: now owned and maintained by Oracle Corporation.
Sridhar Komalla: named after Java coffee, hence the coffee cup logo
Sridhar Komalla: version, history, or Java, 8 most widely used.
Sridhar Komalla: Java, 11 Java, 17, Java 21, which is the latest version.
Sridhar Komalla: And in market, we are having okay, many development tools. I mean, popular ids are intellij, id eclipse, netbase, visual studio code.
Sridhar Komalla: And we do have frameworks. Okay? Based on Java springboard, Hibernet, Java effects, Android SDK key features in detail.
Sridhar Komalla: encapsulation, inheritance, polymorphism, abstraction exception, handling multi-threading collection framework
Sridhar Komalla: so in case, if you would like to know more aspects. Okay, for example, Java, oriented programming concepts, Java syntax and programming framework usage development environment setup
Sridhar Komalla: advanced Java features.
Sridhar Komalla: So in case if you would like to know any of these components, yeah, we can discuss more.
Sridhar Komalla: So let's let's talk about the framework usage.
Sridhar Komalla: So I'll give one full Java.
Sridhar Komalla: Okay, spring example.
Sridhar Komalla: So here is some one simple Java code. Okay.
Sridhar Komalla: so popular. Okay, continuation to the same topic. Popular frameworks by category web development Spring, Mvc. Jsf. Play framework micro services or springboard micronut purpose held in
Sridhar Komalla: for testing purpose. We have that we do have motors, you know. J, you know, test ng, micro heat selenium beltols or maven, gradl a, and T.
Sridhar Komalla: So in case if you want to discuss more about, explain more about any specific framework or examples.
Sridhar Komalla: any integration patterns. Yeah, we can discuss more.
Sridhar Komalla: Yeah, we'll we can discuss more on the integration frameworks.
Sridhar Komalla: So key integration patterns are message-based integration which is like Jms. Apache, Activemq, rabbit, Mq. Apache cough cough. So these are no message based orientation
Sridhar Komalla: programs. And we do have web services. Integration like soap web, so based restful Graphql
Sridhar Komalla: and file based integrations using the Ftp Sftp file sharing document processing database integration like Jdvc. Jpa Hibernet.
Sridhar Komalla: major integration frameworks
Sridhar Komalla: and major integration from Apache camel.
Sridhar Komalla: Okay, which is like enterprise, integration patterns, multiple transparent spring integration mule, Esb. Which is one of the most popular integration tool.
Sridhar Komalla: The purchase address Mics.